allez on se quitte sur une initiative
totalement dans l'air du temps à jouer
les tours les anciens vélos électriques
du groupe La Poste retrouve une nouvelle
vie ils sont démontés nettoyées relooker
avant d'être proposé à la vente aux
particuliers une activité qui donne du
travail à 5 personnes en mars en
insertion on voit tout ça avec Faustine
Luneau
à jouer les tours cette entrepôt de
nouvelles attitude une filiale de La
Poste reçoit chaque semaine en
provenance de la France entière une
trentaine d'anciens vélos de facteurs à
assistance électrique ici ils sont
reconditionnés pour être revendus à des
particuliers des entreprises ou des
collectivités ça ce sont tous les vélos
que nous avons reçu récemment
typiquement s'il y a une montre une roue
arrière mais peut-être qu'on en a en
stock on va pouvoir remonter dessus ça
ne va peut-être pas nous empêcher de la
démonter pour récupérer toutes les
pièces qui sont encore réemployables
cette initiative c'est l'idée de
Jean-Marc Piret ancien gérant d'un
établissement de courrier de la poste ou
des facteurs faisaient des tournées à
vélo suivi
ils étaient mis de côté en attendant
qu'un ferrailleur vienne les chercher
pour les détruire je me suis dit il faut
donner une seconde vie à ces vélos
sachant qu'on puisse les vélos qui ont
une réputation de robustesse de
durabilité
[Musique]
2023 car l'activité s'accélère et va
s'étendre sur d'autres sites de
nouvelles attitudes notamment à Rouen